bonsoir luthérienne romance en
alternance nous sommes toujours en
compagnie de kyan khojandi
alors ok
lolo
laurent wauquiez bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes député ump de haute-loire
réélu avec 63% des voix alors que l'on
avait fait 50 % vous êtes maire du
puy-en-velay où vous avez récemment
interdit le déroulement d'une combi ou
qu alors une zombie walk c'est des gens
qui s'habille qui se maquille en zombies
pour défiler dans les rues alors est-ce
que le clip de michael jackson fuient
leur est interdit aussi au puy-en-velay
en fait en fait la réalité c'est que
j'ai été traumatisé dans mon enfance par
ce clip ouais et donc comme maire je
voulais paraît avoir des zombies dans ma
vie avec la voilà en plus simplement
c'était là tout ça et vous êtes des
c'était une association qui nous a
déposé sa demande trois semaines avant
les connaissais pas bien on s'est dit
bon on va encore attendre qu'est ce
qu'ils font alors ça veut dire un coup
puis on veut les regarde et on peut se
balader comme ça et on peut pas se
balader comme ça voilà c'est même temps
quand je vois les deux photos je
comprends maintenant
il faut comprendre que les jeunes
politiques préfèrent les morts qui vote
plutôt que les morts qui marche les
cèpes à l'usure a beau faire allusion
aux époux tiberi j'étais de nouveau dans
l'actualité cette semaine alors comment
ça se passe la vie d'ex ministres parce
qu'on m'a eue rachida dati qui nous a
confirmé qu'elle s'est acheté un sac
rouge bruno le maire qui nous a raconté
qu'il avait beaucoup écouté de musique
classique écoutés quad vos journées à
c'est moi j'ai ressorti mon vélo c'est
bien honnêtement ça fait plutôt du bien
quand même c'est enfin on reprend un peu
de liberté on n'a pas systématiquement
quelqu'un à côté de vous vous avez osé
plus sarkozy sur le dos surtout
j'ai regardé ça vous fait pas drôle
depuis tous les soirs au grand journal
non
alors là maintenant on rigole plus
demain c'est les élections pour la
présidence de l'ump alors vous vous
n'êtes pas copéiste dans l'écho pays
c'est ce qu'ils sont anti musulman vous
vous êtes fillonniste et vous êtes anti
zombies
dit mais c'est au faux pas totalement
faux ouais c'est à dire que dans le
discours de copé il ya quoi il ya 80% du
discours qui est sur l'immigration ouais
françois fillon lui les plus tôt sur les
questions d'emploi et de pouvoir d'achat
chez coop et c'est un discours qui
consiste à dire la politique c'est clivé
chez françois fillon la logique c'est la
politique c'est rassembler ouais donc
une certaine manière j'aime bien ça
c'est une bonne analyse les anti
musulmans votre les antilles zambie
alors un sujet de filles on vous dit
dans le figaro attention malgré ses
pépins de santé il n'a jamais baissé les
bras sans aucun moyen du parti portée
par l'élan des bénévoles il a mené son
tour de fa mais c'est un sens c'est un
héros non sérieusement même un simple
ici fracturé la jambe ouais il s'est
pris une colique néphrétique loué il
s'est pris des calculs oui moi je les
retrouvais aux urgences à montluçon la
semaine dernière c'est un mec à la
scoumoune un mois
je suis raide au jeu comme précédent
quelqu'un qui sait qui c'est repartir
ouais ils sont denses à penser qu'un bon
capitaine c'est pas celui qui a pas
d'épreuve celui qui en sera la ville
dans les étoiles alors au sujet de copé
vous dites alors là avec copé c'est
marche ou crève il nous a mis un jour un
pistolet sur la tempe en nous disant
sois tu es avec moi soit je te coule
dans le béton il a vraiment dit ça ça
nous étonne beaucoup venant de copé oui
ou non du projet est sympathique mais je
suis très surpris on parle bien de copé
le mec a fait sciences po etc roumanoff
celui vous inviter à votre table et qui
avait l'air très politique mais oui
sincèrement indépendamment de sa c'est
vrai que c'est jean-françois il ya
plutôt une gestion un petit peu que l'on
sincèrement il faudrait répondre à la
question c'est ce que j'ai fait par
sincèrement faire et ce qu'il a vraiment
prononcé cette phrase
je maintiens ce que j'ai dit
vous êtes pour qu'ils montrent fillon et
copé est-ce qu'il a d'abord sa carte à
l'ump
je peux vous faire une carte d'adhérent
si vous voulez je regarde pas trop les
guerres de l'info
alors votre idée avoue en fait c'était
que copé quittent la direction de l'ump
pendant la campagne et qui soit remplacé
par une personnalité
incontestable
le problème c'est que vous avez pensé à
michèle alliot marie
et ben moi j'aime bien mixer la news
d'accord mais on peut pas dire qu'elle
soit incontestable après concours de ben
ali franchement non bon les vacances en
tunisie elles sont expliquées
tu n'as pas de casseroles couscoussière
donc moi maintenant j'aime bien michèle
alliot marie se trouve que c'est qu'elle
s'est faite dans une période où la
politique était totalement machiste on
critiquait non-stop les femmes qui
n'étaient que des paires de jambes à
talons et elle au moins elle a eu le
courage de s'assurer de rester l'air de
bien aller là par hasard enfin bon les
années 90 on sait bien ce que c'était
que d'être réellement politique on se
trouve que là elle a du courage michèle
alliot-marie club avant moi je suis pour
copé parce que ils sont pas près de
revenir au pouvoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il mettait un
peu de bleu